hey reject nation its Greg Alva here
with Lauren Francesco from I want my
Lauren she is I want my Lauren on
everything make sure to follow her on
YouTube and any social media site you
can think of I guarantee you she is
there hey Laura Francesca
what's up from my wall my Lauren you
have seen the it trailer right yeah more
importantly have you seen a classic
movie named Shrek yeah well someone on
YouTube had the idea of what if Shrek
was in the it movie yeah that could
happens an improv being people from the
channel but without a lot of people say
you gotta watch this I take it all
they're gonna do is slice in Shrek over
here if I have a Shirley funny your kid
[Music]
it's our like I knew that was great
I was fantastically that damn dog don't
ever shut up
whenever I'm filming man I saw one that
a different channel did that was it but
with Mike Myers and Cat in the Hat this
one was edited a little different
because they took footage from a
different trailer and they threw it and
Shrek and had to like animate him a
little differently to find there were
some very specific moments of London in
but that was really well done man
that was hilarious I love how you got
scared it was so good for me the real
trailer scared scared me so seeing it
with Shrek it just it's so weird
I like sure I could solo along you know
yeah I found the right moment well yeah
I mean you found a way to make sure it's
scary you brought Shrek back to its
roots Shrek was scary to everyone on
that swamp and now you brought him back
to what made the first Shrek work so
well a horror movie congratulations but
without hey guys subscribe to the real
rejects makes the sub count look flashy
doesn't do much click that notification
bill you probably still won't get new to
five YouTube's funny like that Laura
Francesca on the eyewall my Lauren
channel and on everything else on social
media there's anything you do out of any
things I instructed you to do just now
it is full the Lord on one of those
things it's the main thing you want to
be following on YouTube are on YouTube
yes just funny a sketches on there
plenty of fun blogs as you live streams
the hell of it
yes do it